PROFESSOR: So hello again.
Here we are in
week three already.
It's just amazing.
Week three is going
to be very much a part
of your photographic
exercise to say the least.
It's all about lighting
which, of course, is
what photography is all about.
OK.
So for week three, it's
very straightforward.
It's all about light.
It's, again, very
rich in information,
Remember, watch the videos
which, of course, is essential.
And at the end, part
of the assignment
is using your imagination and
finding new light sources.
For example, I
still am constantly
looking for new ways of
lighting my photography.
Actually, I came
across this, which
is incredibly exciting
piece of lighting equipment.
It's very light.
The name of it is Phlox.
P-H-L-O-X. It's a little pricey,
but I suggest that you take
a look at their website
if you have a chance.
OK.
And finally, an encouragement
to go to the resources.
We have a really
pretty, in my opinion,
very interesting interview
with Brian Hayes,
who is a writer but also
a very fine photographer.
And he and I had a conversation
about technical issues,
which I think that will
be very beneficial to you.
It's mostly a podcast
so you could hear it
sort of in the
background, although I'd
like you to pay attention
to what he has to say.
Enjoy week three.